i'm parker peter parker marvel is
shameless when it comes to revealing all
of tom holland stumbles in the
spider-man movies it's probably
punishment for all the times he spoiled
the plot we're shameless too so here's
every line stumble he had in the mcu
i was hilarious
number one with great power comes
million dollar line flubs i'm sorry i
know i i would if i could but mr stark
and my internship you know one of the
burdens of being a superhero is you've
got to get good at lying it seems
counterintuitive we know i i got a lot
of um responsibility with it
with great power comes great
responsibility that's exactly what i was
going for well at least he finally got
that line eventually number two darling
we live for tom's britishisms
tom holland may have fooled us all for
years into thinking he was american but
that wasn't without a hearty dose of
sass from the casting crew really
letting him know when those britishisms
came out like a grandmother
darling you're british is showing like a
do you not like it not in the slightest
how dare you i've never been so sold in
my life unlike his spidey sense he was
born with it number three peter parker's
parents can't let him throw parties they
let you have parties you know my parents
are dead
some people cry at weddings some laugh
at funerals it is what it is i was told
it was a wedding oh tom nobody tells you
the truth
number four tom's allergic to virgins
i'm a virgin
i'm so sorry
that is totally why i did that luckily
he's not the only one in the
spider-verse with allergies time we
changed too
[Music]
i'm so sorry
yes indeed it looks like the less than
friendly neighborhood vulture is also
allergic to virgins that spider-verse is
a wild place number five tom holland
isn't just good at forgetting his lines
he's great at it but he also gets into
giggle fits that are just too wholesome
for this world or should we say too
wholesome for the spider-verse that's
why we're taking a break from his line
flubs
precious you've been rolling this all
down
why would they stop with gold like this
i don't like this
he does pretty much film projects back
to back to back so no wonder he's gone a
little loopy
number six peter parker is a terrible
friend change our mind look man i really
wanted to tell you where we were hiding
where i was hiding uh oh cat's out of
the bag mj was not with me
so you guys were hanging out without ned
we know mj's peter's girlfriend and all
but ned's the guy in the chair he's
priority number one bros before hero's
girlfriends
number seven is nobody watching the box
where's the box
the box is down there i had to leave it
down there because electro electrocuted
us really tom that's the best you could
come up with says what john was told me
to say yeah
sure see i'm an idiot let's move on
quickly number eight let it be known
that spider-man is absolutely petrified
of spiders you know what given he got
bitten by one and it altered his dna his
fear is actually kind of reasonable you
got a spider web on you that's because
i'm inspired man
if that were the whole bit it might have
been usable divine intervention is a
gift however classic tom broke character
you do it
right there
you should change your hero name to
captain obvi it's on your
burn the whole set down and start again
number nine the show must go on
but that phrase doesn't apply to
filmmaking one bit apparently one little
wire goes awry and tom starts cursing
like a british sailor
they probably wouldn't have used that
take anyways just like they didn't use
that shot of tom getting slugged in the
face but hey now they don't even have
the chance
number 10 one thing you should just know
as an actor
is never cut off samuel l jackson or you
might just get his signature catchphrase
we're almost there
shut the thing on my line like that
glasses case jackson snapped did i do
something
this was the day samuel l jackson
started a petition to replace tom
holland and tom holland tried to make it
better with a gift
this is nick fury number 11. tom's been
double-crossing rdj since day one it
turns out tom never wanted the role of
peter parker after all he was vying for
the role of iron man
i'm i'm not tony this is the real reason
end game ended the way it did he's after
everybody else's roles and we've got the
proof i would become tony stark yeah
because then i could wire tom holland
all the money that he has secret's out
mysterio was right after all i could
give tom allen an iron man suit as a
birthday present tom is pure evil and
then when i finish being iron man for a
day i can be iron man forever number 12
that feel when you try to hold back
laughter and ruin the take by huffing
anyway
my face feels so good
what if we were meant to be together in
another universe
because i want you to stop by that
chinese west indian place wings and
things and pick us up some food our
favorite part about it is that he tries
to look away from the camera as if that
will save the shot
number 13 we would pay to see a travel
show with jake gyllenhaal and tom try
make me laugh
tom holland could not shake the giggles
when it came to working with jake
gyllenhaal and far from home
this i don't think the shot works
i don't think it works but tom was still
the rock that gyllenhaal leaned on for
support entering a whole new world he'd
never previously been exposed to where
whole shooting days could be derailed
and replanned if somebody had a better
idea despite just finishing a one-man
broadway show jake came in the first day
of shooting not being able to remember a
single line he's like i got this please
just believe me you know
there couldn't be less pressure the
first day tom and jake filmed together
and all we have to do is walk up and
shake each other's hands and yet can't
be a tiny bit closer
okay i know when you get to that point
when you're laughing and you're like oh
my stomach they just couldn't keep it
together there's just a lot to take
but eventually jake was able to give a
stellar performance
who's laughing now
number 14. cabbage man doorbell man
caffeine man hippopotamus man one of our
favorite moments is when peter assumed
all superheroes names come from putting
any word in front of the word man
electric man a sandman there's a
dinosaur man we have a question now why
is there a dash in spider-man
and ant-man
but not iron man hmm
number 15. the guy in the chair can't
help you when you take him out of the
chair what do i say hello
so i get up there and i go
hello
yeah spiderman really doesn't know how
to talk to girls at parties hey what
what better way is there to get
authentic awkward moments than to make
the actors improvise entire scenes it's
cruel but it gets results i can't
believe you guys throw parties like this
i'm sorry tom holland is such a gem
truly show us a handsomer funnier
stumblier back flippier actor we bet you
can't did any of these moments make you
laugh out loud too let us know in the
comments and while you're at it give us
your best made-up superhero name too
thanks for hanging out with us here at
the things